hey grammarians so we've already talked
about the idea of the comparative
modifiers right so you know the
difference between saying something is
cute and then saying that something is
cuter than that thing and then looking
at like i don't know let's say we're
looking at a puppy or a mushroom a
little mushroom with a smiley face and
you say oh that's the world's cutest
mushroom
right that's the comparative we've
already covered that i would like to
talk about something i think is a really
interesting topic what's that you say a
really
interesting topic now what's that
doing there in
in this little most little phrase and a
really interesting topic
well it's modifying interesting we
recognize that this is an adverb right
um really is modifying interesting which
is an adjective
interesting in turn is modifying topic
but the question is
what
what does really mean
what is its function
and the answer is that it's a type of
word we call an intensifier so so the
function of really is to just double
down on the idea of interesting so it's
not just an interesting topic it's a
really interesting topic you could also
say it's a very interesting topic or
even an extremely
interesting topic
and that kind of gets us into this other
category which is called adverbs of
degree
so an intensifier let me let me step
back a little bit so an intensifier is a
type of adverb that modifies an
adjective or another adverb in a way
that doubles down on
the modified things meaning so it's not
just an interesting topic it's a really
interesting topic so it's like extra
special extra interesting it it makes it
intensifies it really accentuates or
makes clear the fact that you're trying
to drive home the interestingness
of this topic
but frankly talking about how
interesting a topic is is a pretty good
shortcut for boring so in order to talk
about adverbs of degree i'm going to
talk instead about
the incredibly deadly viper
which is a creature
from a series of unfortunate events by
lemony snicket so the incredibly deadly
viper
there it is there's your terrifying
horned viper yonder voop and and and
what the word incredibly is doing here
is it is um serving as an intensifier
right
but it is also
what we like to call an adverb of degree
um because it's saying the extent to
which this viper is so very deadly
however if this viper had a cousin
that was the somewhat
deadly viper
you know maybe we can blunt its teeth
somewhat maybe it's got like square
teeth
that's the somewhat deadly viper
you know we can see that somewhat this
word here is changing the meaning of the
phrase it's not just the deadly viper
it's the somewhat deadly viper it's its
import has been blunted slightly as have
as have its teeth
and you could also say you know what
what if he didn't have any teeth at all
this this ostensibly deadly viper what
if you just have my little gums
well then he's the
barely deadly viper
instead
and these words like incredibly and
somewhat and barely these are adverbs of
degree so they illustrate the degree to
which the viper is deadly dangerous
so that's that's basically what
intensifiers and adverbs of degree
do
so whenever you see whenever you think
of an intensifier just think of the word
very
you know and when you when you're trying
to figure out what an adverb of degree
is well that kind of answers the
question
how much
so if you want to double down on the
meaning of something you use an
intensifier like very or extremely and
if you want to express
a degree of something you know you could
say
let's say we're talking about like a cup
of tea or something you want to express
how warm it is
you could say it's too hot you could say
it's slightly hot
you could say somewhat
or almost
hot
there are a lot of different adverbs of
degree but that's basically the the
distinction
is an intensifier is powerful but it has
a very narrow usage and adverbs of
degree you can use for a wide range of
uses to express a variety of different
meanings
that's intensifiers and adverbs of
degree you can learn anything dave it
out